these are difficult days
for decision makers not just behind this
door or in this street but for millions
of people beyond it too
ukrainians gathered outside downing
street in protest
the gravity encapsulated in this
national address the prime minister
dubbin russia a pariah state
president putin of russia has unleashed
war in our european continent
he's attacked a friendly country
without any provocation
our mission
is clear
diplomatically politically economically
and eventually military this hideous and
barbaric venture of vladimir putin must
end
in failure in concert with our allies we
will agree a massive package of economic
sanctions designed in time to hobble the
russian economy i say to the ukrainians
in this moment of agony we're with you
we're praying for you and your families
and we are on your side
ambassador is russia a pariah state are
you scared of sanctions ambassador the
russian ambassador summoned to the
foreign office but the meeting last in
less than ten minutes diplomacy
exhausted the focus now on sanctions and
military support
as decades of peace in europe give way
to war
early evening in the pm to the commons
laying out the severity of his sanctions
trade restrictions asset freezes russian
aircraft band and new legislation
promised within days we will continue on
a remorseless mission to squeeze russia
from the global economy piece by piece
cabinet ministers downcast the defense
secretary with his head in his hands and
the severity of the situation written
across the prime minister's face today
mps across the house in rare agreement
the prime minister listening will my
right honourable friend confirm
that the government is putting in place
every possible economic sanction
so that russia feels absolutely the cold
wind of isolation all of us who believe
in democracy over dictatorship
in the rule of law over the reign of
terror
in freedom over the jack boot of tyranny
must unite and take a stand
today russia upturned decades of peace
as it launched one of the biggest
military offenses that europe's seen
since the second world war an invasion
long feared it was nevertheless shocking
when it came so now the sanctions
ratchet up but western leaders know in
reality they have little hope of
changing the course of this conflict in
the coming days as they bed in for a
protracted crisis
tonight ukraine's flag lifted above a
downing street lit up in yellow and blue
a symbol of solidarity in these dark
times
at the sanctions and off minister late
into the evening the meetings here go on
the pm convene in his cabinet do you
have a message to the people of ukraine
tonight
standing with them at the end of a day
that will change the course of this
century
more to do but will it work no certainty
about how or when this ends beth rigby
sky news westminster